It's the end of the sale of vaping products uh
disposable,
often called oxen,
uh and that uh,
please a lot uh to the youngest,
in particular,
who are the first in fact,
to uh use
and well electronic cessica,
to go to tobacco.
I imagine that it is 1 measure
essential that you have worn,
it's 1 essential measure,
And on 2 levels.
So there's the public health issue plan,
you said it,
It is aimed uh,
especially at young people,
they are often middle school students,
there is 1 very aggressive marketing that is done.
Uh, behind it,
uh, those oxen, huh,
they have colors, uh.
Who,
there's also uh.
All 1 work around the aromas,
are often sweet or very fruity aromas,
uh that,
uh that attract the youngest,
And then there's the price,
uh. Which is important,
it costs less to buy uh
1 beef as egg uh.
1 pack of cigarettes.
What is the price about
between 8 and €10 ?
Uh and 1 beef,
how long does it last?
I don't have the.
So it depends.
There is evidence
that are not rechargeable at all
and that last uh.
Like 1 pack of cigarettes,
And then there is evidence that we can recharge
3 or 4 times uh.
And who they
last 1
a little longer than a pack of cigarettes.
Uh. So, uh,
there's the.
2 devices that exist.
And then it's 1 device that goes unnoticed
since it leaves no smell.
So young people can
smoking this in their rooms or even
at school or college,
and you don't notice it,
it goes unnoticed in the kits,
uh. It looks like uh.
1 big, uh.
1 big pen or 1 stabilo,
There is 1 display on it
to say that this is the first step towards nicotine,
Finally,
there is nicotine in it.
So there is no nicotine
in all the oxen in his field,
there is nicotine in others,
there may also be none,
uh. Anyway,
it's not allowed,
uh. Under 18.
But uh.
Despite that,
uh, the.
Uh,
there's 1,
1 study that was done by blend against tobacco,
who showed that young people
manage to obtain them
quite easily in tobacco offices.
And it is also sold in kirska,
newspapers and in supermarkets,
So there are 7 health issues,
since these devices,
unlike vaping devices
rechargeable
that are used to get out of tobacco consumption,
serve the young ones instead uh.
To uh,
to react to it through a gesture and a habit.
And then to the environmental issue,
which is just as important as the issue
supposed to recharge with lithium batteries,
it's lithium batteries.
In fact,
they end up in the trash,
which does not
do not recharge,
or that recharge
3 or 4 times,
And so to give you an idea,
we have very few figures on the French market,
but in any case,
in the UK,
there are 8 oxen per second that end up in the trash,
That's 5,000,000 oxen,
uh, per week.
And uh.
Last year,
what was used in terms of lithium
made its batteries,
it's the equivalent,
11,000 batteries of electric vehicles,
in the world,
uh. So uh,
the numbers in case of replay from one year to the next,
it was very important to get to 1
prohibition.